what we buy and where we buy it has
changed dramatically in recent years
that's why Parliament's updating the
rules on the sales of goods la bonne
nouvelle a lily more cladistics
legislative say Conakry a cada ho pea -
Tom - ah of - Qadri existe occur on
Almaty salsa bromo lead wada
confirmative pocket oh allah Gahan t the
same rules will now apply across europe
whether a product was bought in a bricks
and mortar shop or online if a product
faulty customers will be entitled to
have it repaired or replaced or they
could ask for an immediate discount and
in certain cases a full refund and
because more of the things we buy
involved digital content like apps music
or films similar rules will also apply
to the digital elements of purchases if
you have a defect in your iPhone or
digital camera
somebody has to define how to show why
it is not really working well it is a
software or it is a good Ana normal
consumer is not able to to show it so
from now on customers won't have to
prove that the software or the digital
elements of a product was deficient for
up to one year after purchase doubling
the current six-month limit and this
also applies when customers provide data
in exchange for a service like a social
media account the rules will make it
easier to buy and sell goods and digital
content across borders and ensure that
shoppers are treated equally and fairly
wherever they are
[Music]